[Music]
season 1 left a lot of questions going
into season 2 what was your number one
question and did you get your answer are
we going to keep telling the story
without the book because we have the
book as the template in the first year
and without that I mean the writers
could have done anything so I was I was
just curious and excited to get my
script so I just you know devoured them
it's just what freedom looks like The
Handmaid's Tale is back for season 2
that scope of this show is so much
bigger than last year right I mean it
feels like an epic with more Alexis
Bledel what was it like to get to
explore who emily is and learn more
about Emily I was so excited to flash
back and get to depict the story of who
she was free chiliad show her kind of in
all her glory thriving you know doing
what she loves working as a professor of
cellular biology and you know loving
being a mom and her family life that's a
very full life and and how crushing to
see her ripped away from all of that I
mean I think it really you really feel
what a shame that is to take to take
things away from a woman who is thriving
it's such an honor to play this
character you know the fact that she's a
mom it's a huge part of who she is and
you know certainly makes up a big part
of her worldview in the colonies we see
her caretaking you know so you
definitely see that maternal instinct
coming through and I don't know I just
love playing her the colonies it's a
pretty dark world what was that like as
an actress what did you have to tap into
for that I was just interested to see
what came forth you know for Emily
standing there working and that's you
know soil
you know would be contaminated and I
found that she you know while she has
lost some hope she still had this sort
of sense of personal dignity because she
knows that what is happening to her is
not just you know it's not right and
she's able to hold on to that piece
which you know was something that came
to me
[Music]